this whole house which is doing more to
protect children
gambling is an adult activity and it
must remain an adult activity that is a
major reason why I applauded the
decision taken by the Premier League to
remove gambling sponsorships from their
shirts from their shirts fronts in
coming seasons and it's the same reason
we are ensuring children can do no forms
of gambling either online or on widely
accessible scratch cards
finally we know the current status quo
disadvantages casinos bingo halls and
other traditional premises compared to
their online equivalents
a number of assumptions which prevailed
at the time of the 2005 act now look
increasingly outdated so we plan to
rebalance regulation and remove
restrictions which disadvantage the
land-based sector
Madame Deputy speaker almost every
Member of Parliament will have met
constituents whose lives have been
blighted by gambling
gambling harm that is the online world
has transformed so many parts of life
and gambling is no exception it is our
responsibility to make sure our rules
and regulations keep up with the real
world so we can protect the most
vulnerable whilst also allowing everyone
else to enjoy gambling without harm
I look forward to working with every
member of this house to bring forward
our gambling rules into the digital age
and I commend this statement to the
house Shadow Minister Alex Davis Jones
Thank You Deputy speaker I also thank
the Secretary of State for this update
and for advanced sight of her statement
I too would like to pay tribute to all
of those campaigners who have long been
calling for better reform and regulation
of the gambling industry the shadow
secretary of state had given her
apologies for today long before we knew
of this statement so I'd like to let the
house know that today but Madame deaf
Seeker what we all know to be true is
that updated gambling regulation is long
overdue the last legislation on the
statute books is from 2005 long before
the huge rise and growth in online and
mobile gambling opportunities as a
consequence people have also now have
the ability to gamble constantly and
make huge losses in a very short space
of time I have met with many people
whose lives and whose families lives
have been devastated by gambling harm it
is because of them that this house comes
together cross party to call for better
relation of gambling anyone can fall
into gambling addiction so we need a
modernized robust system which is fit
for the future from Bingo to the races
some forms of gambling are of course a
traditional British Pastime around half
of adults participate in some form of
gambling and the vast majority do so
with enjoyment and in moderation indeed
as an example bingo halls are an
important part of sustaining our local
communities especially in coastal and
Rural towns and let us be clear Madam
Deputy speaker bingo halls and adult
gaming centers and casinos are facing
their own pressures in terms of
skyrocketing energy bills and concerns
about the sustainability of their
business models in the face of
significant online competition is
therefore welcome that there is
distinction in the announcement between
bricks and mortar bingo halls and low
stick adult gaming centers with the
dangers that are unique to the online
World by much push to the Secretary of
State further here although we have
waited a long time for this statement it
is very light in substance so can she
confirm exactly how lamb based and
online gambling forms will differ in
terms of their level contributions this
is an important point and I urge the
minister to clarify both for the
industry and for the 110 000 people
employed in in the industry
what is the economic impact assessment
been with regards to the treasury for
this announcement the government has
delayed this white paper many times
everything they're announcing today was
ready to go a year ago six gambling
ministers four culture secretaries have
all promised to publish this white paper
imminently that being said Madam Deputy
speaker we welcome many of the measures
in the announcement which are many of
the things we've long been calling for
and it is a move in the right direction
she mentioned the Premier League's
voluntary ban on gambling adverts on the
front of shirts however this really is
quite weak the voluntary ban as it
stands doesn't cover Holdings or even
the sides or back of shirts it also
won't come into effect for three years
so in that time what is to stop the
Premier League from reverting on their
voluntary ban once public attention is
moved on will the minister be pressing
them Premier League to go further I have
some further questions about today's
announcement which I must press firstly
as I said we welcome the levy but can't
you tell us exactly what this Levy will
be in addition labor welcomes the new
powers for the gambling commission but
the minister must confirm if they will
get extra resource to match this
additional responsibility the gambling
commission have already been found by
the Nao to have insufficient capacity to
regulate the industry and now they'll
have further things to regulate so is
the shadow secretary confident they will
have capacity for the expanded role
they'll take on in terms of
affordability checks we know that
further sharing between gambling
companies is badly needed and I awake
details of the checks in the
consultation however it is vital that
affordability checks are set
independently from the industry so can
the Secretary of State provide us
reassurance on this that brings me to my
next point the minister makes reference
to stake limits and safer by Design
mechanisms which of course we welcome
but will they be based on how dangerous
a product is who will decide that it
took years and the resignation of a
minister to get stake limits on fixed
Arts betting terminals so can she
reassure the house that these limits
will have teeth and reduce harm from day
one
finally it is clear that we need greater
protections for children and under 18s
so will these measures cover stronger
action on loot boxes and other in-game
features that are proven to lead young
people to be more likely to experience
gambling Mental Health financial and
problem gambling related harms Madame
Deputy speaker labor has been clear that
we stand ready to work with the
government we've been ready to stand for
a long time to tackle problem and
harmful gambling and we have repeatedly
called for updates and to this
completely outdated legislation the
government has a real opportunity here
to do the right thing to make positive
real world change for the better the
secretary of state must commit to
getting these updates Over The Line in
good time the time for more and more
consultation has been ongone so can this
actually stay confirm and commit to
passing all of these necessary statutory
instruments before the house Rises over
the summer she must crack on and make
good on these long overdue promises I
look forward to further clarification
from the minister over the points I have
raised and ultimately work together to
tackle gambling at its root
Secretary of State oh well I I thank the
shadow Minister for her comments and
Shadow Secretary of State also made her
apologies to me so I'm very grateful uh
far and understand the reasons for her
absence I'm pleased that she said that
we need to update the rules and this
measure would have cross party uh
support I very much look forward to
working with the Shadow from bench on
something that is uh so important as she
mentioned the delay uh Madam Deputy
speaker but and I would like to
reiterate a number of things one is of
course the measures that we have taken
uh over the past few years which I
mentioned uh in my speech whether that's
cutting States on fixed odds betting
terminals Banning credit card gambling
reforming online VIP schemes or
introducing new limits to make online
slots safer she will know that I have
been in post only two and a half months
this has been a priority for me I have
brought it in I would say with some
speed and that speed and timeliness I
think that she can be confident will
continue to ensure that these measures
Make It Forward into the necessary
regulations we're bringing many of these
measures through by statutory instrument
which will speed up the process and I
very much look forward to the shadow
Advantage cooperation to ensure that we
can bring these forward these measures
as soon as possible
Damian green
Deputy speaker I congratulate my right
Uncle friend for finally finally uh
getting this white paper uh published
and I particularly welcome the
introduction of the statutory Levy which
she will know has got great support on
all parts of the house the most
disturbing fact I've learned in
preparing for the select committee's
upcoming investigation into gambling is
that at this moment there are something
like 50 000 children who are problem
gamblers in this country that is a truly
shocking figure so could my right
honorable friend expand more on the
really essential measures uh in her
proposals that will protect children
from this terrible scourge
to ensure that uh we protect children
and that's why in addition to measures
that are already in place ensuring for
example targeting of advertising does
not play take place towards children uh
there are a number of measures including
the ban uh the voluntary ban that's
taking place on uh football shirts but
not just that as I mentioned we are
ensuring that gambling is illegal when
it deals with uh monetary gambling up
until the age of 18 so we will be making
it illegal for children to take part in
scratch cards or
slots that produce uh cash and of course
the statue Levy that he raises is so
important because it is through the
statutory Levy that we can continue to
look at research on how gambling affects
children and can take any necessary
measures in due course
SNP spokesperson John Nicholson thank
you very much indeed Madam Deputy uh
speaker and can I thank the Secretary of
State for advanced uh site of her
statement we have consistently
encouraged and pressed the government
for Action in this area and as other
honorable and right honorable members
have said a dozen ministers responsible
for gambling have come and gone since
change was first promised clearly the
2005 Act is out of date and it grows
ever more relevant to Modern gambling
realities by the day those vulnerable to
harm especially children are not well
protected under the current legislation
at my party these benches and I will
approach this important discussion with
constructive dialogue to support
evidence-led legislation from the outset
perhaps the Secretary of State can
outline the role the precise role of the
Ombudsman especially when it comes to
protecting children because I know
members on all sides are deeply
concerned with a huge rise in gambling
amongst children
uh we will work constructively with the
government we know that gambling
destroys lives and I'd like to pay
tribute to so many charity workers and
others who've pressed for these changes
and members across the house on my
benches in particular The Honorable
member for Andrew Clyde who's worked
tirelessly on this we will work
constructively with the government in
assessing what the Right Way Forward is
that protects the vulnerable from harm
thank you
oh well I'm very grateful for that
constructive approach I very much look
forward to working with him
um on the measures as they as they
progress he mentions the non-statory
Ombudsman that is an important measure
to ensure that we redress the balance
between punters who feel that uh uh
their issues have not been addressed
sufficiently and the company is involved
that's why we're bringing forward a
non-stractory
Ombudsman on which we'll be Consulting
in due course so we're in Duncan Smith
well David speaker I'm grateful can I
first of all say to my vulnerable friend
I welcome what she has announced there
particularly want to pay tribute to
those on the all party parliamentary
group the leadership with the member for
Inver Clyde and for Swansea East
particularly I think if it's one of the
East who has uh with us driven this uh
like a Unstoppable power and a force of
nature so I play a particular tribute to
her can I just say that I welcome this
David speaker because this is at least a
start I think it's a positive start I
think most of the recommendations made
by the all party group are in here and I
welcome that as well but there are a
couple of areas one is to recognize this
is about online harms and the the most
harm that's been caused is from the
online companies uh physical betting
shops Etc are not part of that process
and I think therefore when she looks at
those land-based areas she'll recognize
when it comes to the levy the statutory
Levy the majority of that should be
borne by those who are doing online and
and that is important the second thing
is on advertising in children I simply
want to say to her
not far enough I don't mean to be
cherlish about this because I welcome it
but I do say this voluntary position uh
by companies uh to have uh advertising
off their shirts children I'm a season
ticket holder for Tottenham they don't
have a Betting Company in it but many do
and children wear these things and they
go to school sometimes in them and they
advertise there for these gambling
companies on their shirts so we need to
recognize this is a permanent process
even if they move it to the arms uh the
point that you made it may who knows in
two years they'll slowly Creep from the
arms to the front so I would say when
you consult on this come back with the
decision that actually we need to take
control of this but I welcome this Madam
Deputy speaker it's a step for security
and safety and Common Sense and that has
to be welcomed by the house
uh well I'd like to begin by commending
my right honorable friend for all the
work over he and others have done in
this area and it's because of the points
that they have made in their tireless
campaigning along with those who have
suffered terms themselves you know and
their families it is the result of all
that work that we are standing here
today able to bring forward this white
paper
um he he particularly mentions young
people and I share his concern we must
do more which is why we are taking steps
to make gambling illegal in so many
other forms uh for people who are under
18 and I I do welcome the Premier
League's announcement in relation to
front of shirts uh being banned because
uh footballers are role models for our
children uh and we don't want to have
young people going around advertising
gambling on the front of their shirts
they like to wear their football shirt
so I welcome oh that voluntary move
that's been taken by the Premier League
which I know me and uh princesses have
incar the Premier League to take of
course we will look carefully at
evidence and uh that comes forward with
any uh with us with the funding from the
statutory Levy and all these matters
under review
Kevin Brennan
Madam speaker and I thank the Secretary
of State for her statement and just
managed to get a copy of the the white
paper it was widely reported that um
there might be restrictions on over 18's
introduced as part of the white paper
but looking at the white paper it
appears that it's more a commitment to
um consult on asking gambling companies
to think 25 rather than for think 21
when when going about age verification
given the real issue we're trying to
deal with is children gambling could she
just explain what the thinking is behind
that particular provision
and it is appropriate to also protect
people who are over 18
um and perhaps under 25 and when he
manages to read the whole of the white
paper I hope he will see our our
proposals in relation to online slots uh
where there will be a consultation on us
on a smaller amount of money that could
be bet by children by young adults
between 18 and 25.
Damian Collins
thank you um I congratulate the
Secretary of State and the officials in
her department on the work in producing
this review does she agree I agree with
her that the gambling commission needs
to be a data Savvy regulator can she
confirm that they will be able to run
independently the background
affordability checks without causing
friction in the system but also
importantly I think the the rules that
run the Gathering of data and the use of
data to Target advertising under power
and to drive customers with loot boxes a
lot of those industry rules were really
written for the pre smartphone world and
the gambling commission needs to make
sure that vulnerable players are not
being data profiled and targeted
makes them a very important points and
I'm very pleased to have had the
opportunity to discuss these issues with
him given his expertise and knowledge in
this area he mentioned the play
protection checks those will largely be
background checks that uh will be
seamless and frictionless Tech checks
that will take place only affect 20 of
people and and most of them will not
know that anything is taking place but
are really important to ensure that
gambling companies take their
responsibilities seriously to check what
is happening as I said in secret he also
mentions loot boxes he will know that
the the government is is working with
companies and pressing them to ensure
that there are protections there as well
uh Carolyn Harris yeah as chair of the
government related Harmony PPG I welcome
this long overdue but white paper and
the appg's 2019 interim report we asked
for affordability checks parity with
land and online Stakes an independent
nombisman a coupon advertising and most
importantly a statutory Levy job done
the apbg also pushed against strong
backlash from the industry for all of
the reforms that the Secretary State
mentioned earlier not least fobts
measures on VIPs and credit cards but
today's progress it may have taken eight
years of campaign and nine culture
secretaries and 10 changes in hair color
but it's progressed nonetheless today is
a momentous occasion that many thought
and many wished would never happen but
now the commitments need to be fulfilled
we don't need more consultation we've
had two and a half years since the
review we need Swift action immediate
implementation of The Proposal ourselves
an urgent legislative change where it is
necessary after 18 years of the gambling
industry's dominance over this agenda
now is the time for leveling up so I
asked the secretary of state will she
commit today to ensuring that these
changes are brought in as a priority
with no delay in tactics let us protect
those who have lives have been affected
by gambling related harm and let's stop
lying in the pockets of an industry who
have had it of their own way for far too
long yeah yeah well I'd like to thank
and hugely commend The Honorable member
for Swansea is for all her work
um she she has highlighted we have
listened and taken action
um and I really do comment her and thank
her for for her work as I said I've been
in post for for two and a half months I
brought this legislation for she cannot
uh she can be reassured that I will
continue to ensure together with my
junior Minister that this action happens
swiftly she will know that following on
from a white paper there are various
technical consultations that needs to
take place we need to bring forward
these measures uh largely through
statutory instruments and that is a
process where she has my utmost
commitment to ensure that that is done
as speedily as possible
Philip Davis thank you speaker and can I
refer people to my entries in the
register of members interests can I ask
the Secretary of State how many regular
punters she spoke to before bringing
forward these proposals particularly in
relation to affordability checks at the
rather bizarre and arbitrary figures of
a thousand pounds a day or two thousand
pounds over 90 days which I think
amounts to 22 pounds a day by my
Reckoning the conservative party used to
believe in individual freedom and
individual responsibility but that seems
to have gone out of the window with
these affordability check proposals can
she tell me when an affordability check
is made who decides whether or not an
individual can afford the amount that
they're gambling will it be the
government will it be the gambling
commission will it be the bookmakers or
will it be the banks and do the punters
themselves get any say at all over how
they can afford to spend their own
hard-earned money
I I thank my honorable friend and for
his engagement uh on this issue and I I
know that he uh like many others wants
to ensure that people punters who enjoy
a bet or enjoy a flutter are not
prevented from doing so he asks what
engagement we've had 44 of adults Gamble
and we've spoken to quite a lot of them
we've had 400 meetings on this issue to
ensure that we take into account uh all
perspectives and this is about this is
the legis the white paper that we're
putting for today is about balance it's
about ensuring that people can go about
their business doing what they enjoy
without restriction but at the same time
protecting those people that need
protection and those those checks that
he talks about and most people will not
even know that they're happening they
will be frictionless they'll happen
behind the scenes for 80 of people able
nothing at all for 20 of people that
will just be is simply a check on
whether you've been made bankrupt or
whether you've got a county court
judgment against you you will not know
that that check is taking place it's
taken those sorts of checks take place
in a whole variety of different
instances but they are there to ensure
that in the very small percentage of
cases where an operator needs to double
check that somebody it might be going
down the wrong road that those checks
take place those I should emphasize
those checks are already taking place
gambling companies already have a
responsibility to ensure uh protection
of those that gamble with them and what
we're trying to do is to protect people
like the nurse who spent 245
000 pounds over a period of a few months
when the gambling company knew that she
had a salary of 30 000 pounds those are
the sorts of instances that we want to
stop with our proposals in the white
paper Clive effort the deputy speaker I
welcome today's today's white paper but
can I just ask a question on the issue
of the statutory Levy because it's all
well and good imposing a statue of Levy
and I welcome that but how that money is
used is vital and it has to be
independent of the industry the
researchers have to have access and free
and open access to the data and they
have to be free to choose what research
they Undertake and those in the gambling
industry should not have any sway over
what is researched and what is not yeah
well I can get
says he want that they will not have a
say in what the money is spent on and we
will ensure that that money is spent
appropriately
Stephen crap
Deputy speaker I welcome the tone that
the minister is striking today and uh
tackling problem gambling and
particularly protecting vulnerable
people is of course essential does the
minister recognize that the gambling
industry whether it's to everyone's
taste or not does have a symbiotic
relationship with Grassroots sport in
this in this country and not just horse
racing so what steps is the minister
going to take to ensure that with the
regulation that she is rightly taking
forward we don't damage Grassroots sport
in this country
[Music]
friend because he's
been used of billions of pounds who is
putting money through its taxes to
support many of our public services and
for the majority of people
um it is offering something that they
enjoy so that is why we're trying to
strike this balance uh this balance
between allowing that to continue whilst
at the same time protecting
um problem gamblers there are we
estimate around 300 000 problem gamblers
and and and protect those at the same
time
money count
what's my name speaker and welcome to
staple now the time to the 250 pages of
the white paper and I'm sure the devil
is definitely going to be in the detail
I'm not as enamorable statement as other
members seem to be I'm related our hard
work has been recognized I think it's
really important today to reference the
hard work of those campaigners the
people with a lived experience the
people who've lost loved ones who've
completed suicide through the addictions
to a gambling and hard work they've done
to bring me to this place and allowed me
to express their opinion to a Smart Life
answer was the Smart Life equation was
incredible one of my delighted here the
industry are not going to have their
fingers and that pie that money must be
ring things and Channel Through the NHS
was used properly I'd seen one lane this
demon says working with industry and
gambling commission I would just caution
there they are part of the problem and I
forgot to work with them you have to
work with people who have experienced
the gambling harm in the first place
it's got a balanced viewing this in our
Draco the sentiments I've only been from
the checking book and saying if we're
taking football advice off the front of
shops for EPL teams voluntarily that's
should be encased in law what happens to
kids who follow a championship team our
first division team are established him
an SPL team in Scotland that was shown
on Stonewood being exposed to this
adverts and network acknowledging that
they do harm that adverts do harm
they've all got to do all got to go all
shots all around the stadium all around
the pitch in between games on the
television on the radio advertising does
harm all advertising has to go
uh where I'd like to commend uh The
Honorable member for the work that he's
done and it
in this area and also he he rightly
recognizes the work of a whole range of
gambling uh campaigners who are have
been affected by this issue and I'm
really pleased to have met many gambling
group many gambling campaign groups to
hear their stories and see how they uh
have been affected he's right to talk
about advertising towards young children
and that's why it's already prohibited
to Target adverts towards young children
I I must say we we must welcome while
the premier league has done and as I
have said the statutory Levy will enable
us to look at this issue further and if
necessary of course we can take other
steps in the future Craig Whitaker
Deputy speaker and can I refer members
to my registered interest as well my
right honorable friend has said that she
wants to protect the vulnerable with
this review which is a name that
everybody in this house wants to achieve
but you can understand my surprise
though that in a statement we see no
mention of the fact that in just under
half an hour you can Google non-gambling
aware bets and you find over 400
regulated sites with no protection or
checks for the vulnerable we see little
or or no mention of the scourge of
scratch cards to protect the vulnerable
and I also didn't hear a mention uh
companies that are for-profit
fundraisers who openly advertise to the
vulnerable as well so will my right
honorable friend agree with me that
unless gambling in the round is
considered and in a balanced way the aim
of protecting the vulnerable will still
be being debated in this place in the
next 20 years okay well I thank my
honorable friend for his points it is a
very extensive white paper and many
people have mentioned the 250 pages and
within that there are a lot of
Provisions to protect a lot of people
um he he rightly mentions uh that we
need to stop Hunters going to the black
market and we need to strengthen
gambling commission and local Authority
powers and resources and that's one of
the things that is highlighted in the
white paper that members will have an
opportunity to read when they have a
little more time the the regulator will
be able to block or take down Black
Market operators and where necessary
suspend or take away licenses from
companies which Break The Rules as well
as I mentioned already we are increasing
the age for a number of other types of
gambling
at Paul Bromfield thank you madam
speaker and can I thank the Secretary of
State for acknowledging the work of my
constituents Liz and Charles Ritchie and
for her engagement with them and indeed
the engagement of her predecessors
while warmly welcoming much in this
statement as I do I know that Charles
and Liz will be along with other
families bereaved by gambling addiction
deeply disappointed by the failure to
tackle advertising and particularly in
football
she rightly highlighted and others have
too the shocking number of children
who are addicts or have problems with
gambling
11 year old and and
younger now for many football is the
hook
now in the action that they took the
Premier League recognized
advertising is harmful
but a front-of-shirt ban isn't enough
fans are exposed to an average
700 ads at every Premier League game
now other countries have acted
so will the Secretary of State think
again on that issue because the campaign
for comprehensive action on Advertising
won't stop
area
okay well I Thank The Honorable member
for his points and it's been an honor to
speak with the riches who have
articulated uh their case uh so well
um and I know that they and others would
like us to go further as I am sure the
gambling companies would like us to go
less far and so what this why paper does
is seek a balance between allowing
people to go about their lives who are
not suffering harm at the same time as
protecting those people who
unfortunately are harmed we the position
already is in relation to advertising
that you cannot Target advertise
advertisements should not Target
children we've seen their measures taken
by the Premier League which the
government was uh very very firm and
made it position very clear to the
Premier League as to the action they
they ought to consider taking and as I
have already mentioned we will look very
carefully at any further research that
comes out and would take action if that
was necessary
to Desmond Swain will she take this
opportunity to review the uh dated and
rather severe regulatory regime in which
the lot of postcode Lottery and the
hospice lotteries have to operate under
[Applause]
um enjoyed by uh communities one of the
changes that we are making is in
relation to raising the age to ensure
that we protect young people but always
happy to continue look at the work that
they are doing
Deputy speaker and can I refer to my
entry in the members register the
minister read out almost a race card of
her predecessors and so can we
congratulate her on this in the short
time with which she's managed to get out
this white paper to get a much better
public debate but isn't the danger that
any regime will be vulnerable to
Offshore out of jurisdiction operate
operators who flout the regulations and
undermine legitimate companies so will
she mobilize a whole of government
approach including the crime agencies
the treasury and the banks to tackle the
gambling Black Market to ensure the
success of her reforms while also
protecting a major British industry and
its workers
yeah General member makes an important
point because people have said to me if
you tighten up the rules uh in relation
to legitimate gambling all you're going
to do is drive punters offshore and that
is why in this white paper we are also
stopping punters going to the black
market because we're strengthening uh
the gambling commission and local
authorities powers and resources and the
regulator will now be able to block or
take down Black Market operators and
where necessary to spend or take away
licenses from companies who break the
rules
Celine Saxby thank you madam Deputy
speaker and very much into the same vein
whilst welcoming so much of today's the
secretary of state is quite right that
it is the Advent of smartphones which
has seen such a change in gambling
behavior and what more is actually being
done so that if you choose not to um
pursue a legitimate operator because you
don't want the affordability checks or
some of the other new regimes just
pressing Google and finding so much more
is there going to be more being done
really to clamp down on the black market
particularly when it's so accessible
just through your handheld device
uh yes I can confirm that the regulator
will be able to block or take down Black
Market operators or where necessary to
spend licenses licenses from companies
who break the rules
Jamie Stone
Madam Deputy speaker 400 people a year
round about that number particular in
lives each year into going homes it is
rather a personal issue for me and for
my home committee because a much-loved
GP
and 2007 did exactly that and he still
missed today we all mourn his passings
of a moving Memorial to him outside the
local Health Center
so can I can I say to the government can
we crack on with this as fast as humanly
possible because you know if we'd had
this legislation some years ago this
gentleman might might be still with us
say
um well
my thoughts are with all those who have
lost their family members and I hope
they will look on today as a a moment
which they have contributed to I know it
has taken some time but I would like to
point out my deductive speaker that this
is the largest reform that we've had
since 2005. it is game changing
um and it was it is of course right that
where we bring our regulations up to the
smartphone age we take the time to make
sure that we get those regulations right
Mark Fletcher
thank you speaker I welcome today's
statement and look forward to reading uh
the white paper and the measures within
it however it does feel like a sense of
deja vu in that every time we look to
clamp down on an area in which people
vulnerable people are being exploited
and the gambling industry profits off of
their vulnerability they move on to find
a new platformer a new method in which
they can exploit so what sort of
confidence does the Secretary of State
have in the future proofing of these
measures and will she commit to making
sure that there are constant reviews of
this legislation because the gambling
industry is very powerful and has a big
but and very persuasive approach to this
place and it is important that these
vulnerable people are protected
oh my
rosette to ensure not only do we keep up
with what's happening in technology but
we also have the evidence to back up any
policy changes that we need to bring
forward in millions
and Deputy speaker and the end of
gambling company sponsorship on Premier
League team shirts is of course a
welcome step by the Premier League but
that's not until the end of the 2025
2026 season three years ends it is not
good enough there's not enough
urgency within that and everyone who
watches Sports coverage particularly
football on TV are constantly bombarded
with images and repetitions
advertisements urging them to party in
gambling games spot bets betting offers
for particular scores or match outcomes
what are children watching those matches
on TV meant to do hide behind the sofa
cover their eyes put their fingers in
their ears it they're being bombarded
constantly by this it has become far too
normalized and it is we know damaging
lives now with regularity I action and
urgency is imperative
I I I recognize the points they
honorable members making but I I would
like to
congratulate the Premier League on the
action they've taken because they have
talked about it for a long time and they
have now taken action and so too today
the white paper brings in a large number
of options uh actions that really will
make a significant uh difference uh of
course we will uh obviously uh con keep
matters uh under review but the statue
Levy will help us and enable us to do
that Greg Smith thank you madam Deputy
speaker it was Everlast that when
governments ban or curtail legitimate
activities underground markets do bubble
up to fill that void and I was struck by
uh some evidence from The Institute of
economic Affairs that shows even without
things like stake limits five percent of
UK gamblers have used unlicensed and
unregulated sites and half could
actually name a site to go to to gamble
in an unregulated way so whilst I hear
the measures that she has outlined
around greater powers for the gambling
permission gambling commission to shut
down Black Market operators what is that
has she made of the volume of current
gamblers that could move to underground
at gambling and does she think that the
gambling commission even with their new
powers would actually be able to keep up
with that
so it is important that we ensure that
we protect people
um from both legitimate gambling where
we have problem gamblers but also
um the black market I would just like to
emphasize uh one important point though
because some of the measures that we've
brought in today are already being uh
are already in place for some companies
so some responsible companies are
already taking measures that we have
announced today and they have punters
and they have successful operations the
issue is that not all companies are
doing the right thing and so what our
measures do is seek to ensure
consistency across the board so that we
ensure that the people are right they're
doing the right thing are not prejudiced
and that we protect those people who
might become problem gamblers
the secretary of state has said in her
statement that she will ensure that
children can do new forms of gambling
including online gambling can she
confirm whether that will be through an
age verification process and how exactly
will that operate
and while it is already the case that it
is illegal for people to be
um gambling online and there are also
some Protections in place and of course
we will continue to ensure that those
protections are strengthened French
thank you madam Deputy speaker uh
clearly there is a delicate balance
between addiction and the safe enjoyment
of gambling and as always the devil will
be in the detail what assurances can my
right honorable friend provide today
that these proposed reforms will not
negatively impact people's enjoyment
without the races or perhaps a football
bet on a Saturday or a night at the
bingo and also our much loved British
sports including horse racing which
employ thousands of people across the UK
directly and indirectly
for those people who are betting
occasionally and if a matter of
enjoyment these these uh measures will
not make any difference though those
people will still be able to enjoy their
leisure activities what these measures
are designed to do is to help and
protect those people who are problem
gamblers whose lives are potentially
going to be ruined so I you know I still
encourage those people who want to take
part in what is an enjoyable and
leisurable Leisure activity for millions
of people across the country we're
trying to strike the right balance there
Andrew Quinn thank you I welcome a
number of the measures that she's set
out today including the statutory Levy
but also importantly I think for most if
not all of us in this house uh the
protections for children and young
people particularly in the online sphere
given that technology moves at a great
pace and many of the advances that we've
seen in technology and the problems
associated with it when it comes to
gambling since 2005 could not have been
foreseen 18 years ago what assurances
can she give not only the rules that
she's setting out now will be updated in
future but also that the powers and the
resources and the capacity of the new
regulator will also be kept up to date
with the moves in technology
fundamental that we continue to look
at technology change
I remember mention the statutory Levy so
the statutory Levy will enable us to
have research make evidence-based policy
but it will also allow if appropriate
um education education of young people
so that even when technology changes
they understand the issues that may face
them
Shannon
um okay first of all thank thank the uh
um the uh so just get very much for the
statement uh and on the gambling act
review I I failed and been manifested
here positive progress so well done such
a state or not I myself had concerns
with the accessibility of gambling on
smartphones I don't want to ask a
specific question if I can
um as a photo of the ID to prove it aids
on building UPS is necessary some under
your pins have been buying fake IDs to
enable them to bet on the Range online
so what discussions has the secretary of
state had with large betting
organizations to do more in-depth
straightening
of ID used for betting thank you
uh the people do not gamble under the
age of 18 and of course betting
companies have to ensure that people are
following their rules Robert Ferrier
it's because there's a beach chair of
the gambling related harm appg I thank
the Secretary of State for her statement
and welcome the long awaited white paper
those parts of it I don't agree with but
that's for another day this one's the UK
saw the opening of the first women only
Residential Treatment Center for
gambling addiction it's catered towards
women's needs including a consideration
to child care demands as women on
average spend less time in treatment
than men for this reason there's a
minister agree that this highlights the
need for an intersectional Public Health
focused and treaty access treatment
program which offers tailored support to
those who require it
I was very pleased in my engagement to
speak with clinicians who are dealing
with gambling harm and I'm very pleased
that the statutory Levy will ensure that
NHS trusts will take the funding that
previously they have turned away because
of where the it was coming from so I do
think that the measures that we're
bringing forward today will help those
people get the support that they need
I thank the Secretary of State for her
statement and we now move to business
statement leader